it's like yoga almost do you like I'm
gonna break this yeah this is a struggle
when you've been at work all day you get
high and the first thing you want to do
is take a pee bra and this is the best
way
[Music]
it's not that complicated but unless
you've seen it done a bunch of times I
think it's confusing to the brain
I've seen people take their bra off it
seems super simple one foul swoop it's
very impressive
it's an art it does kind of appear like
a magic trick a little bit my sister
would do it all the time as a gay man I
don't even really quite understand the
bra strap situation in the back
I don't know the mechanics of it I have
taken one bra off of a high school
girlfriend she's not a lesbian I am now
gay that's how life works well I think
I'll be able to do it with a little
struggle I'm not allowed to rip it right
I'd like to think I can do it but it
might take a little practice as well I
think I'm gonna struggle but I think
I'll get it my game plan is go from
front to back I believe in myself fact I
think it's going to be very hard for me
BAM
oh all right so now I have a prong I
don't know if you can tell but I got a
nice green bronze I feel like I'm want a
bra before in my old theater days
stretch out a little bit gonna start
taking this bra I don't know why this
was my first dates date see No so first
things first
reaching my back oh wow okay not as bad
as I thought uh so I guess I have to get
no wait no so sir can I use two hands is
that what is that what normally happens
okay throw my shoulder out I'm going
around the back I'm gonna try it unclasp
that was one hand which is no oh oh I
got clip done I got one there too clear
there's like three back here see I don't
even know the mechanics of a bra I think
these are hugs yeah yeah this is a
struggle ah you got to do this first
these are these stretchy enough though
they won't break definitely don't want
to ruin it I can't even like find where
it goes how do you guys make it so easy
oh my god I can't do it how much I do
the way that I've seen women do it
picture it they do to that it's not
trying to impress anyone I don't need to
use one hand wait which way am I
supposed to go
it feels like there's three hooks I
think I have one undone okay come on
Christian you're not incompetent this is
like yoga almost feel like I'm gonna
break this oh I think I did I know a
fossil
oh my god this is so tough I'm like
sweating there are three cooks I'm
trying to get at least one out oh I got
one out I got one out got another out oh
I got three out okay oh okay I didn't
have one done but now I do
going for the middle one oh man I should
stretch before that I'm getting really
sweaty oh I did it okay ooh she's free
Wow is this how girls normally take them
off
okay maybe stretch a little bit
ouch uh-huh yes I even asked a friend
like what is the secret she's like oh
you just it's really quick lies
logically I think my sister would like
do something like this
should be like in the backseat like now
that's done just gonna do this oh my god
this is not as bad as I thought okay oh
wait I got one almost there
did it okay I got it on latched is it
like this is that did I get it I hope
this is new yeah wait is this count if I
do this that count does ice business
count I'm so sweaty yes and yeah I think
that's it I actually just be over
found look at that Wow yeah there so I
figured it out tap there it is
you did it okay that's not that bad look
you did it my first bra taking off I'm
very happy about this I'm very proud not
too shabby
it was way harder than I thought it was
simple ish like I had to figure out
where the clips were and it was hard
that I expected I overthought that I
think was a good workout my sister would
do this in like a second they make it
look so easy and effortless you know
it's something one of those things you
don't think about taking it off after
maybe 30 seconds of wearing it I did
feel this relief so I can only imagine
how it would feel taking off after a
full day I feel liberated
my breasts feel free I do have man boobs
so much respect for you out there
[Music]